Now that we know what the reorder buffer is supposed to look like let's see
how it's used. For that we need a reorder buffer with its commit and
issue points and we need the rest of the processor that we have already seen.
The instruction queue, the reservation stations, registers and the RAT.
Let's say that we have this add instruction here in the instruction queue.
So now we want to see what happens once we start issuing this all
the way to once we eventually commit this instruction. In a process that now has
a reorder buffer. So let's see what happens when instruction issue. As before,
when we didn't have the reorder buffer, we get a free reservation station. And
we put our instruction in it. Now that we do have a reorder buffer we will also
get one of those, unlike reservation station, where we just need a free one,
it doesn't matter which one it is. Here we need to get the entry that is
the next one at the issue point. So, R instruction will go
here in the reorder buffer. That of course also means that our
issue point will now move and points to the next entry in the reorder buffer. So
now we have seven instructions that have been issued and have not yet committed.
Another thing that we had to do, when we were issuing instructions into
Tomasulo's algorithm, is that the RAT entry for R1. The destination
registry of the instruction needed to be pointed to the reservation station for
the instruction. We will still need to do this pointing, but instead of
the reservation station, now we point the RAT entry to the ROB entry for
the instruction. That means that this RAT entry will be now instead of pointing
to the reservation station be pointing to this entry here.
So overall at the end of the cycle when we issue this instruction,
we will occupy reservation station with the values that we found for
these registers. We will make the RAT point to the ROB6 entry. And
in this entry, we will say that R1 will need to be written for this instruction.
And we don't still have the value, so the done bit is 0 here for
this instruction. Now this add here might wait for operands to become ready.
And that happens exactly as before with Tomasulo's algorithm.
We just capture results that we need, and we are ready to dispatch once we
have all the operands. Eventually, the add has all the things that it needs to
dispatch. And the dispatching works exactly the same as before. So, we check
whether the operands are ready. And when they are, we send the instruction for
execution. But now we can also free the reservation station as soon as we
dispatch. Previously with Tomasulo's algorithm, we needed to wait for
the reservation station release all the way until this instruction broadcast its
result. That was needed because the reservation station serves as the name for
the result. Now that the name for the result is the ROB entry,
we no longer need the reservation stations to play the troll.
So the reservation station now does only its primary job, which is wait for
operands and capture them. And then, figure out which instructions to dispatch.
After that the reservation station for the instruction is done so
we can free it. So now we add executes and carries with it the tag of ROB6
which is the name for it's result. Eventually it produces a result.